prometic nature mois cette pétition
signée par plus de 300 personnes en
majorité des résidents du sud de l'île
au bénéfice de l'accusé du meurtre de
sébastien peso les faits se sont
déroulés le 18 janvier dernier dans la
bo de rivière-pilote deux hommes depuis
l'hôtel du sud aux profils bien
différents
la victime âgée de 33 ans et inconnu de
la justice
tout l inverse de l'accusé 55 ans père
de famille de deux enfants selon un
témoignage et jouissait d'une bonne
réputation
malgré un cv handicap par rapport à une
précédente agression
c'est pour cela nous fait nous décider
des répétitions pour nous ainsi qu'à
tripoli d'affaires donc nous sommes chez
vous et où tu es qu'il faut partir des
côtes d'agneau mais où nous nous cadix
un geste de légitime défense parce que
sinon ces liquides et kate ont fait des
doléances adressées aux magistrats de la
chambre de l'instruction mais aussi à
l'avocat de la famille de l'accusé
on m'a fait parvenir une pétition de
neuf pages de voisey y compris des gens
de la famille de la victime qui disent
que l'on résumé c'est dommage que ça
soit tombé sur mon client puisque en
plus de ça c'est un handicapé et que
c'est tout le monde dit que c'était
quelque chose d'extrêmement gentil mais
ils disent quoi ils disent que tout
autant ça devait arriver
une pièce importante versée aux débats
et analysées par la chambre
d'instruction
pourquoi je les versets parce que la
mise en détention a été motivée par le
trouble à l'ordre public
le trot ballon public jeudi que le
trouva le public n'est pas n'est pas
actuelle puisque en fin de compte les
gens demandent plus à ce qu'il soit
libéré parce qu'il reste en prison
aujourd'hui c'était demande de liberté
provisoire a été rejetée par les
magistrats de la cour d'appel de fort de
france pour mettre selenis ce n'est que
partie remise
il espère qu'au cours des enquêtes
diligentées par le parquet que les
magistrats ont peut-être une autre
analyse de ce dossier et que son client
pourra bénéficier d'une éventuelle
remise en liberté provisoire avant
d'être a dû devant les magistrats de la
cour d'assises de fort de france